the jurogan experience when you go back
and you know i feel like if you think
about like your your times playing
football like your great times
versus your great wins in in fighting
like what what is more satisfying to you
there's no
drug there's no
anything
that you could do to repeat replicate
the emotions and feelings after knocking
the [ __ ] out and i'm not like
talking about like teeth like getting on
top and hitting them to the right pulls
you all
like one punch boom he's you know jello
on the ground like you might have killed
that guy there's no better feeling
and i've won like uh when i played
football we weren't playing the national
championship i had a bit of a pretty big
play at the end of the game that kind of
sealed it but even that the last game of
my college career
doesn't equate to knocking out japan on
the tall
the way i did it just doesn't it's one
on one it's you versus me
and i just did that to you
it's just
and i've you know
done quite a few drugs i've you know i
had quite a few big moments yeah
uh other side of the coin there's no
[ __ ] lower feeling than getting your
ass whooped
uh in front of
you know not only the crowd but the
people on tv
and uh you know so
but i'll take a dude i'll [ __ ] run
the risk of
that versus the high you get after a
knockout or a win
uh and you know any day do you remember
the feeling of like your first loss
where you're like oh geez
this is different
yeah because my first loss was to uh
machida and i feel like i beat machida i
just so happened to fight him in brazil
and i think that he thinks that he lost
because you know before they read the
scorecards his head's all low and he's
you know
kind of pounding and he's like oh winner
by split decision machida and all of a
sudden he thought wow
but that was not a loss like a
you know that was like not like thiago
santos loss it wasn't you know yeah um
i think uh you could have won that fight
yeah i remember that fight you could
have won that fight i had his back and
uh you know
yeah i was in that fight but um i kind
of liked
or told myself anyways that i kind of
liked pushing myself
like i like the challenge you know
and uh you know two fights later you
know he's [ __ ] fighting for the
championship
and to be honest like i think that's
kind of the fight that
put me on the map even though it was a
loss you know i think the people liked
like these two big [ __ ] just
stood in the middle and just
swung on each other until one couldn't
anymore and
you know from the fans perspective i
think they really like that so yeah it
was definitely in bad a big fight but
but it's not like a fight like a serious
loss
yeah
uh
roundtree was pretty devastating um just
because like there's something about
that day i was just like dude i don't
wanna fight i do not wanna [ __ ] a fight
i'm gonna do it anyways but
don't really wanna be here right now
what do you think that is i have no idea
because i mean all the preparation all
the training dude there's some fights
like when i made my debut i had zero
nerves and as soon as my feet touched
the canvas and i felt like
how grippy it is i was like dude he's
dead this motherfucker's out of here i
know he's i know i'm finna win but that
roundtree fight in particular i was i
remember walking to the cage like
maybe someone puts a banana peel out
here and that [ __ ] slip like oh dude
i don't can we do this tomorrow is that
the only time you've ever felt like that
to that extreme yeah yeah yeah
what do you think that was i don't know
and i was really confident going into
that fight because i didn't think that
he could wrestle i was watching film i
was like dude he's never like just
flat like he's dropped a lot of people
but that's he just dropped him like he
never like knocked him unconscious i was
like all right even if i do eat one i'll
[ __ ] still be alive and be able to
fight and [ __ ]
but i don't know dad i just woke up on
the wrong side of the bed and i was like
[ __ ]
that's what you were talking about
earlier when you're talking about khabib
and usman and these guys that like every
single time they're mentally there yeah
that's probably one of the hardest parts
of the sport got to be
and these other fights were like
hopping again this dude's ass and it's
going to be held for him so i don't know
what that is um if you wish i'm a sports
psychologist
yeah they all say different [ __ ] and you
know
one guy said just be happy to be here
and i'm just like that's preposterous
and i would just no dude i used to make
fun of people like oh dude he's just
happy to be here he's for sure if
anything speed or whatever or don't
worry about the outcome as i know dude i
am worried about the [ __ ] outcome
because that's half my money you know
you lose a fight i could get cut yes the
outcome absolutely matters stop talking
to me